[Music]
the following program contains the
opinions of its host and guests not
those of this network the opinions
expressed are for non-commercial
informational purposes only listeners
are cautioned not to rely on program
content to treat or prevent disease but
are advised to consult with a licensed
health care professional where they live
for diagnosis and treatment of disease
and now the superstar of alternative
health and purveyor of medical truth dr.
Joel Wallach hello and welcome to dead
doctors don't lie dr. Joel Wallach your
host a veterinarian and physician and
I'm here for kids and baby boomers and
seniors who don't want to die at seventy
five point five like their parents and
grandparents I'm here for kids and baby
boomers and seniors who don't want to be
sick and miserable for the last 15 to 20
years or live like their parents and
grandparents I am a conservative people
say I treat them like dogs but they do
seem to get better now if you have a
personal health challenge when asked
about if you have a health challenge of
a friend the loved one or work mate or
if you want to talk about medical
politics to the home based business
opportunity give us a call toll-free one
800 units toll-free one intraplate three
seven nine two five five two well we
have to continue talking about the
pre-existing conditions and of course
the Senate has pulled the health care
bill because they didn't have enough
clothes to pass it so you up not now
we're gonna start talking about taxes
the health care bill pushes dead at
least for the President and so the
accelerated death spiral for Priya for
the you know the American health care
bill is accelerating faster and faster
and faster so it's time for people
really to get involved begin to do these
things themselves because the
government's failed in the medical
systems failed them I mean we ranked
43rd in the world would come to
longevity
our children be the first generation
that Americans that do not live as long
as their parents um the third leading
cause of death in America the third
leading cause of death in America is
medical mistakes and hospitals alone
each year by medical mistakes and
hustles doctors kill its words Johns
Hopkins news kill two hundred fifty one
thousand Americans what would happen if
United Airlines were to kill two hundred
fifty one thousand passengers what would
happen if one of the fast-food
restaurant chains were to kill two
hundred fifty one thousand customers in
a year what would happen if North Korea
or Iran were to send over an
intercontinental ballistic missile the
horrible weapon and killed two hundred
fifty one thousand Americans it'd be a
war here's one trade that does it every
year in the workplace they don't even
get an OSHA ticket I'll get a wok high
five have their pina coladas in Lake
Tahoe
okay so I urge you to contact your hungy
associate get a hold of the book
epigenetics the death of the genic 3z
transmission the book dead dr. lie and
the CD and DVD go along with them and of
course the book rarest ventures don't
forget my newest CD a stick of butter
day keeps the doctor wait and then of
course public enemy number one and dead
doctor and why 2.0 all these things are
way to educate yourself and see what you
can do to save yourself and your
families because the medical system has
failed you the government's failed you
so let's look at some of these
pre-existing conditions they're just
driving insurance cause skyrocketing and
doctors are just throwing up their hands
and walking away going back to school
and becoming lawyers it can't make
living as doctors anymore okay
so let's look at central nervous system
let's just look at the brain and spinal
cord and most people don't realize
doctors certainly don't realize it that
the brain and spinal cord require all 90
essential nutrients 16 minerals 16
vitamins 12 minutes of 3 fatty acids and
without them you get these horrible
spectrum of diseases they're all
preventable and most of them are easily
dealt with and you can get them you know
the body in the brain in the spinal cord
to heal itself okay let's look at
dementia there's five major dimensions
you can have a little v you can have two
three four or five you have one but no
matter which one or which one
you have doctors will always diagnose
them as Alison disease because get paid
the most from from the insurance code
books when you're diagnosed announcer
disease as opposed to the others we're
talking about Korsakoff syndrome warning
to coruscant syndrome vascular dementia
where you get the same plaque in the
arteries that you find in kearney heart
disease and so forth these are caused by
inflammation fried foods processed meats
are also gluttonous totally reversible
you have to just change the document or
the bad stuff the fried foods the
process means the oils of glutens and
then you throw in one healthy brain and
heart attack 400 pounds of body weight
and throw in the ultimate daily classic
tablets ultimate daily classic tablets
three twice a day 400 pounds of body
weight and they will support promote
healthy blood flow through blocked
arteries and if you've given up all the
bad food and stopped the ongoing damage
arteries will repair themselves if you
keep doing the bad stuff eating the
fried foods processed meat I was in
gluten there is no nutritional
supplement program that can outdo a bad
diet so you have to do both you have to
give it all the bad stuff it caused
problems in the first place and then you
supplement properly in your body will
guilt oh then let's look at there's a
little class of pre-existing central
nervous system disorders including
Parkinson's disease MS multiple
sclerosis Huntington disease and see
here what else I guess I guess as the
class and these are these are all caused
by a deficiency of fats and certain
nutrients so again the healthy brain and
hard pack one 400 pounds of body weight
you know all the bad stuff all the
inflammatory things no fried foods
processed meats also glutens you also
have to throw in six to eight eggs a day
per 100 pounds of body weight so if
somebody weighs 120 pounds I have me
eight eggs a day they can be soft
poached Assaf yolk soy sauce yolks on
stall scrambling butter no fried no oils
no margarine no cooking oils no olive
oil no cocoa all that's got to go and
the brain can repair itself including
the myelin all these things and of
course Huntington disease on to be a
genetic disease one of the famous people
who had it was Woody Guthrie you know
kind of a folk singer a mess multiple
sclerosis there
Richard Pryor Michael J Fox and
Parkinson's disease
oh yeah and Lou Gehrig's disease that's
another one that's in the same class am
Alex Trebek lateral sclerosis all four
of these is these are the same as these
it's just a matter of dumb luck which
part of the brain has more damaged in
the other part of the brain and so it
will exhibit different symptoms or
causes the part of the brain that's
afflicted the more severe will give you
a different symptom and so they're all
approaching officially in the same way
I've seen miraculous results it's
amazing what the body can do when you
stop the ongoing damage and give the
body the realm of trills to deal with
these things
okay I urge you to contact Jung Joo
associate say hey I need epigenetics the
death Integrity Commission the book the
CD and DVD dead doctor the lion don't
forget rarer Fincher's will be back with
dead doctors don't lie you're listening
to dead doctors don't lie on the CBS
radio network with your host dr. Joel
Wallach if you'd like to talk to dr.
Wallach call between dune and run
Pacific at eight three one six eight
five one zero eight Europe toll-free 888
379 255 two
[Music]
many believed that all life began in the
Earth's oceans we do know that the
oceans and seas are still abundant with
life and life-sustaining nutrients many
cultures have long believed in the
life-giving properties of plants and sea
life harvested from the oceans young
Japanese oceans gold is a proprietary
blend of seaweeds algie's losses kelp
sea cucumbers and sea minerals as well
as coenzyme q-10 calcium and iron all
designed to help support healthy thyroid
function regular heartbeat normal weight
food stabilization and hormone levels
take advantage of life-sustaining
nutrients from the Earth's oceans with
youngevity oceans gold if you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about home-based business
opportunities hi everyone Andy Anderson
here are you using those handy little
bottles of gel that zap germs bacteria
and other nasties in today's world
that's smart especially with all the
filthy doorknobs shopping carts and
handrails we touch everyday here's what
you may not know once the alcohol
evaporates goodbye effectiveness no more
protection until you use it again pure
works to the rescue our FDA compliant
foam lotion soap and spray do not rely
on alcohol they're killing power lasts
up to four hours pure work disinfecting
spray is EPA certified to kill swine flu
bird flu mersa HIV hepatitis B and C and
a whole host of viruses and bacteria
mold and fungus - it's even safe around
children and pets
you'll love the soft feel a pure works
on your hand it actually conditions that
will not dry your skin here's a little
peace of mind knowing your hands are
still germ-free hours later get your
hands on pure works and yet pure works
on your hands stand by it pull out your
paper and pencil for your local number
to order pure works
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors online the
CBS Radio Network dr. Joel Wallach here
if youngevity life crusade we do ham
lines open give us a call toll-free one
for blade three seven nine two five five
two again as toll-free one triple eight
three seven nine two five five two and
if you're gonna do the youngevity
business as a business I urge you to
contact your young juvie associates get
ahold of that trilogy of books let's
play doctor let us say herbal doctor the
password grown therapy learn how to do
your own physical for four dollars and
fifty cents compared to two thousand
dollars for doctor doing it oh yeah when
you do your physical yourself it won't
get on your chart and your monthly
premiums won't go up and your co-payment
won't go up huh
look at that and you'll probably get it
better more honest and safer diagnosis -
all right and of course I want to get
ahold again the books legislature Lister
herbal doctor passport Roman therapy
learn how to deal with over nine
hundreds of diseases using vitamins and
minerals and trade journals and rare
earths amino acids fatty acids herbs and
Roma therapy Liz it's a trilogy of books
let's play doctor let's be horrible
doctor the passport Grumman therapy
you've never owned your own business
before also get the book Wall Street for
kids and learn how to be profitable and
learn how to do a business plan so your
youngevity business can pay for your
monthly health insurance premiums your
life insurance premiums your fitness
center monthly fees your qualification
requirements for youngevity and honor on
or not okay those two trilogy of books
and wall street for kids okay Doug I
thought we talked about obesity as I've
got a fox news story your headline the
u.s. pays high price for obesity they
say us adult who's healthy but obese
will eventually cause society tens of
thousands of dollars in medical care and
lost wages according to a new study
they used a computer model to estimate
the financial toll that obesity
typically takes affirm that and an obese
fifty year old with normal blood
pressure and cholesterol levels will end
up costing society more than thirty six
thousand dollars is a societal figure
included people's direct medical care
for obesity related disease
lost productivity for disability or time
off work and they said according to dr.
Bruce Lee associate professor at Johns
Hopkins Bloomberg School of Public
Health says what folks struggle with
their weight it ends up affecting
everyone and he's a senior researcher
you say obesity contributes to a range
of chronic health conditions such as
type 2 diabetes heart disease and
certain cancers it ultimately raises
everyone's health insurance premiums
according to Lee says you're paying the
insurance premium that and the co-pays
and if you if your productivity has
reduced that that affects your wallet to
set on the other hand team found that
weight loss could bring big say across
savings estimated that an obese 20 year
old that shed enough controls to drop
down into the overweight category almost
two-thirds of their lifetime cost a to
society would it be avoided plus they
say that there are health benefits of
losing weight well beyond the age of 20
if a healthy but obese seventy-year-old
across the overweight category and a lot
her lifetime costs will be cut by about
40 percent and they go on to say so
weight loss is cost saving at any age in
the USA has to be two-thirds of adults
are obese or overweight according to a
spokesperson for the obesity society and
founder of consonance Health Ted Kyle a
spokesperson for this group says this
which advocates for the evidence-based
approaches to addressing obesity says
the study really documents the cost of
untreated obesity which is the norm in
this country and I said for example
diabetes prevention program involved
intensive counseling on diet exercise of
behavior modification large US
government study found that the program
slashed the risk of type 2 diabetes
among overweight at-risk adults and goes
on from there through this so like
you've always said doc you know take the
rev it changed your diet go to
gluten-free diet or you could easily
lose weight oh absolutely and of course
we've been running on a false theory for
125 years and that's why we're the
number one obese nation in the world
something like 40% of Americans are
overweight and obese 40% with a number
nation in the world and the zoo to
nutritional deficiencies one class of
nutrients if you're deficient any one of
those you're going to gain weight if
you're deficient two or three of those
you will be overweight or maybe even
obese there are three of them any one of
those three in that class of nutrients
if you're deficient any one of those
you'll be the 300-500 person you need
all the exercise you want you can
restrict your done you'll lose a little
bit of weight through your gain it all
back cause you can't stay in a 500
calorie diet forever
well I urge everybody to contact your
young give you associate get ahold of
the hotels kitchen the subtitle is the
Claus brunch and curb obesity it also
discusses type-2 diabetes and metabolic
syndrome don't forget the book energy
crisis and learn how to use the keto
caramel's shake and Aikido terrible meal
bars and the rev as you pointed out and
you lose a half a pound or 2 pounds a
day in the magic is you'll never gain
the weight back as long as you stay on
your 95 bad food will stick with us from
impact more truth justice and the
youngevity way on doctors don't lie
after these nothing you're listening to
dead doctors don't lie are the CBS Radio
Network with your host dr. Joel Wallach
if you'd like to talk to dr. Wallach
call us toll free 8 8 8 3 7 9 2 5 5 2
off the priority right eight three one
six eight five one zero eight zero
[Music]
the antioxidants founded middie fruits
and vegetables are known to help support
and promote good health research has
also showed that dark chocolate once
known as the food of the Gods is rich in
healthy nutrients in fact dark chocolate
is higher in antioxidant content than
any other food youngevity has combined a
proprietary blend of velvety rich dark
chocolate with whole fruit pulp and
whole fruit juice extracts from
mangosteen goji or wolf berry acai berry
and cherry along with vitamins and
minerals producing a smooth rich
delectable concentrate called cocoa
Gemma tea it tastes so great I sometimes
drink it right out of the bottle or pour
it over ice cream cocoa Gemma tea is
highly bioavailable meaning your body
will absorb and make use of all of these
healthy nutrients if you'd like to learn
more about nutritional supplementation
call your local youngevity associate and
don't forget to ask about home-based
business opportunities hey if you're
like me your life is hectic you don't
know where you're gonna be next between
kids and family and in-laws and work and
traffic and everything else that's
driving me crazy right now my life is
insane I bet your wife's insane as well
when do we have time to get every single
nutrient we need to be healthy when well
I've got a tip for you take a product
called pollen burst it's so simple even
I can do it all you have to do is open
the package pour it in water mix it up
and bam you're ready to go it tastes
great it's not one of those medicine
tasting things it tastes great low in
calories helps curb your appetite gives
you natural energy that doesn't let you
crash gives you your vitamins minerals
nutrients everything from the plant
world and I gotta tell you for a busy
person like me or a busy person like you
we need simple we need good
palm verses your answer tastes great try
it and you'll feel better call your
local youngevity distributor to find out
how pollen burst can make you feel
better
ahead don't forget to ask about
home-based business opportunities you've
listed a physician and veterinarian dr.
Joel Wallach helped many people on the
dead doctors don't lie talk radio
program you've also heard hundreds of
people tell how dr. Wallach and
youngevity products have changed their
if you're now convinced that dr. Wallach
is onto something and you want to try
your Japanese premium quality products
for yourself we could connect you with
the distributor that serves your local
area simply call our special helpline
voicemail at three one three four four
four 3463 that's three one three four
four four three four six three call
right now and leave your name telephone
number or email address and we'll see to
it that the right person contacts you
shortly remember the phone number three
one three four four four 3463 that's
three one three four four four three
four six three call down to change your
life that's three one three four four
four 3463
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors and wine a
CBS Radio Network dr. Joel Wallach here
for youngevity 95 per se we do hand
lines open give us a call toll-free one
800 units full three one triple eight
three seven nine two five five two and
again if you want to live to be well
beyond 100 chronologically say 110 120
130 140 150 160 170 180 hundred ninety
two hundred plus well being biologically
thirty forty fifty contact our young GV
associate and as for the books
epigenetics the death of the genetic 3 z
transmission book in mortality and learn
why the top 20 longevity cultures
according to the National Geographic at
40 times 100 olds we Americans do they
have 100 over 252 population we only
have one per 10,000 what gives there and
don't forget to book rarest vineyard
written cures epigenetics immortality
and rare earth ventures and of course we
have the CDs dead dogs and why is he a
stick of butter day keeps the doctor
away public enemy number one and the new
one dead doctors don't lie 2.0 all right
and so let's see here
mmm I guess you got to take the night
you don't forget the 90 that's important
gotta get to 90 and make sure you're
taking all 90 essential nutrients
appropriate for body weight all right
let's go to colors alright let's head to
Orange County California ed Paul you're
on with dr. Wallach
hello Paul you're on the air Oh
congratulations
I've 128 pounds and I have two problems
Nate my my right hand goes numb and it
starts hurting and I wake up and I
cannot go back to sleep okay when you
say goes down is that when you're
standing it goes down or when you're
laying when I'm in bed you know and goes
oh so sleep oh no no okay no okay and
that's the right hand primarily okay
just sleep on your back or your stomach
or your side
I sleep on my right only right or left I
never sleep on my back okay on your side
only okay so okay what's problem number
two
tell them to is the macular degeneration
guy I found out after having two kids
that actually moved and I have to use a
magnifying glass to read
okay so megavision generation Ellen you
had that well I guess I had it all the
time I didn't know if that's right he
moved my cataracts sure doctor then
found that I hadn't met another
generation okay well what question for
you what do you attribute your long life
to what do you what do you attribute
your success at living v92 anything in
particularly attribute that's it I do
eat a lot of fruits and vegetables and
protein chicken etc can you eat eggs
well I started I heard that heard that
you're recommending 8 X 8 8 x per day
only take I take only three eggs and I
grind sweet and sunflower seed and seed
ride them in a coffee grinder putting in
my eggs anything together
excellent okay excellent very good thank
you for sharing that sir
okay charmagne yes oh we got hang on
here dear and get your thoughts together
we'll be back when the help fall out
here he's got a peripheral neuropathy
and his right hand when he lays down
only when he lays down and macular
degeneration loss of vision because of
the changes as I believe back we'll give
him a protocol after these messages
you're listening to dead doctors don't
Lyle the CBS Radio Network with your
host dr. Joel Wallach if you'd like to
talk to dr. Wallach call the priority
line eight three one six eight five one
zero eight zero toll-free 888 379 255
two
[Music]
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian dr. Joel Wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors dough by
talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your Japanese premium
quality products for yourself we could
connect you with a distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call right now and leave your name
telephone number or email address and
we'll see to it that the right person
contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call down to change
your life that's three one three four
four four 3463
hi this is dr. Joel Wallach your host of
dead doctors don't lie if you're
interested in a colon cleanse blood
cleanse liver cleanse in a classical
herbal way you want to ask your
youngevity associate for herbal
rainforest herbal rainforest has 16
herbs 16 cleansing herbs classic
cleansing herbs and 77 plant minerals
that's right and these are all organic
it doesn't get any better than that
and your busy day and you're around all
these toxins out there in your workplace
on the way home going to work in your
food in the air in the water you need
herbal rain clothes I guarantee it it
will give you a cleanse you can control
the dose it's a liquid it tastes good it
doesn't get any better than this a colon
that's happy makes you happy
nothing better than a happy : herbal
rainforest clean it out for more
information on this product or others
you've heard about all the dead doctors
don't lie radio program call your local
youngevity associate today and don't
forget to ask about home-based business
opportunities greetings everyone
Judy developers here what do you think
of when you hear the words tangy
tangerine well I think like a sweet
tangy tasting something
well what I'm referring to is the
ultimate tangy tangerine it
a fantastic product it has everything
you need and a great benefit is it's
very very delicious it's very easy to
drink I've suggested it even to
youngsters even children like even
little guys even little girls they come
right into my office their parents can't
get them to take those chewables and
besides that they're not as good as
tangy tangerine and I give them a little
taste of that and you know something
they're pleased as punch so if it's good
for a child and it tastes delicious why
not you there's no excuse not to take a
vitamin when it tastes as good as that
does so how about it tangy tangerine
should be the answer to all of your
nutritional program problem for more
information or to order call your
youngevity distributor today and don't
forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities this
is the CBS Radio Network Network
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the CBS radio network dr. Joel
Wallach here for youngevity 95 to say we
do hand lines open give us a call
toll-free 1-800 free one triple eight
three seven nine two five five two and
if your energy the youngevity business
as a business again I would urge you to
contact your young give associate and
get all over that trilogy of books let's
play doctor let's favor Bulldog from the
passport chromotherapy
and learn how to deal with over 900
different diseases using vitamins and
minerals and trace minerals and rare
earths amino acids fatty a served
aromatherapy oils nothing you learn is
how to do your own physicals and you'll
learn how to identify parasites you'll
learn how to find out every kind of
disease you can think of yourself for
just a few dollars and test strips you
can get from the pharmacy without
actually getting a prescription so save
yourself a lot of time money do not get
things put on your permanent records so
that your your cost of your health of
insurance premiums go up your life
insurance premiums go up and deal with
this yourself save an enormous amount of
money and they had twenty-five to fifty
health of your life the trilogy books
let's say doctor let's the herbal doctor
in the passport gorilla therapy okay
Doug let's go right back to California
and Paul okay Charmaine yes okay Paul's
92 years old weighs 128 pounds and when
he lays down only his right hand goes
numb what do you think that is what do
you think is causing it I think if he's
got arthritis obviously he's got
arthritis knee general just disease in
his neck and upper back okay and that's
not unusual for somebody over 70 years
of age right and so okay so what would
you do for him 128 pounds to support
maintenance repair the discs in between
his neck and his upper back so we can
deal with this peripheral neuropathies
right again
well he could take good gel for that
however what I would do for his issues
all the different issues he has is I
would give him one healthy brain and
heart packed and then I just to lean him
and give him the gluco gel in the
vitamin d3 okay very good so one healthy
brain in hard pack a habit of everything
twice a day but he said
the sleeve again I'm an extra bottle
seems I can take six of those a day
three prices three dinner or two
breakfast lunch and dinner then he needs
to gluco gel to support Maine's repair
of the disc
Quarterly's ligaments tendons connective
tissue there'd be two large bottles a
month so you have 15 a day five at
breakfast five at lunch five at dinner
and then the vitamin d3 perfect for a 92
year old guy three of those capsules
twice a day are three of the spritzes of
the liquid citrus vitamin d3 either way
and let's see here that I covered all I
think yes I believe we did okay and what
would you do for his max regeneration
he's got the loss of some vision here
max regeneration which is kind of like
liver spots in the retina the lining of
his eye what would you do for him for
that and you know add on to his existing
program now well you know selenium is
good for doing all those things however
we do have a new product that anybody
could try to use further for it's
obviously for vision called called acute
acute if I could tell ya I started
taking it and yeah octave and they come
30 in a bottles and take two bottles a
month six take one of breakfast one
dinner time very very powerful product
also what liquid antioxidant would you
give him it comes in court liquid
bottles well think of the Zebras in
Africa imagine a radical book yeah I
could take that yeah you could take two
ounces a day the Z radical comes in
quart bottles so you take an ounce of
breakfast on center tremendous powerful
very very wonderful antioxidant and then
were there any I said it comes it comes
from grape seeds what would you give him
from that maker take the OPC T or the
other one I nature's pearl yep yep the
OPC T has green tea and grape season and
the nature's pearl grape seed extract
tremendous antioxidants go for it
Solomon calls
every two weeks we'll watch it through
this buddy we back with dead doctors
don't lie after these messages if that
does open alarmed if you'd like to talk
to dr. Walley call us toll-free 888
three seven nine two five five two on
the priority line eight three one six
eight five one zero eight zero
[Music]
[Applause]
you've listed a physician and
veterinarian dr. Joel Wallach helped
many people on the dead doctors don't
lie talk radio program you've also heard
hundreds of people tell how dr. Wallach
and youngevity products have changed
their lives if you're now convinced that
dr. Wallach is on to something and you
want to try your Japanese premium
quality products for yourself we could
connect you with the distributor that
serves your local area simply call our
special helpline voicemail at three one
three four four four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call right now and
leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
3463 I am Judy devel bus here I am
speaking to you again I just wanted to
tell you that recently I started
drinking the way shakes again the
chocolate way shake and you need to
remember the way shake isn't just for
losing weight it's a fantastic place to
get your great protein and if you're
trying to gain weight you can take it
along with your meals and the best part
is if you want to just have a great
protein shake do like I do put it over
ice stir it up and you can sip on it
for twenty minutes to an hour I do it
every single day I absolutely love it
you need to get back to it - it's really
good for you and it makes not fat but it
makes muscle after you workout and you
can also mix it up in a blender with an
egg and you have the most incredible
health protein shake or mix it with a
little water stir it up and you have a
little pudding and who doesn't like
puddin for more information or to order
call your youngevity distributor today
and don't forget to ask about youngevity
home-based business opportunities
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't line
the CBS Radio Network dr. Joel Wallach
here feeling tivity 95 Sade we do have
lines open give us a call toll-free
1-800 soul free one triple eight three
seven nine two five five two and if you
throw your hands up and say this is all
so complicated I don't know anything
about biology I didn't like health
courses or scientific courses in school
what do we do here how do I learn about
this well contact your young associate
and asked for this bundle it was put
together by Jimmy Osmond or the Osmond
family he followed me for two years and
filmed me lectures all kinds of
presentations interviewed me in the
studio for six hours put all this
together and this bundle contains the
book the DVD and the CD is called a
truth about nutrition everybody even if
you think you know everything needs to
get ahold of that bundle called the
cruise about nutrition and you will just
learn some great things it'll help you
not only help yourself but help you help
your loved ones and help your friends
your church mates your neighbors your
workmates and they were you getting all
this embrace you just say oh the truth
about nutrition ok Douglas Oprah call it
alright let's head to Pennsylvania and
Priscilla you're on with dr. Wallach Oh
Priscilla you're on the air my son is 51
years old he's a diabetic two years ago
he had his right pinky toe amputated and
a bone in his left out of that foot he's
in the hospital now this is the second
time this year yeah
got an infection in the bottom of his
right foot the doctor told him this
morning that he had two choices because
there's an infection in the bone he
could amputate another toe well cut off
his foot he also has acid reflux so he
would like to do an alternative sure
okay two things
two things here Priscilla how much does
he weigh I'm big a fella is he 160
pounds okay I guess three questions it
type is type 2 diabetes or type 1 psyche
- okay now as a kid did he have any
asthma or bronchitis or skin problems
eczema dermatitis or psoriasis no he
didn't have any of those things okay
mmm did he have bowel problems
constipation diarrhea diverticulitis and
the side is anything like that okay do
you have any other children here
Priscilla he didn't have any asthma skin
problems rubella poems sure okay sure
main what's going on here um they have a
gluten intolerance that was passed on to
them by the mother but also he has acid
reflux which tells you he's not
absorbing and that's a big problem yeah
he's not digesting he's not absorbing
and so he if he wants to do something
optional aren't alterative amputate in
his foot he's got to do what sure mean
what does he have to do for his diet
well I have to change his diet he can't
have any gluten and he's got to you know
not eat the bad foods he can't eat any
kind of oil
no burnt animal fat no and he's got to
eat butter and a and ya know pride - no
fried - right here with all that no
gluten or wheat bran oat sure exactly
right and so at a hundred and sixty
pounds what we could give him to support
healthy blood sugar well you know
something you get ready for all these
issues what I do is give them two
healthy blood sugar packs but I'd also
add they I'd also add some selenium to
that okay couple
- a bottle smoking take 3 20 day what
would you do for circulation and blood
pressure and all items I give him some
ultimate very classic ultimate daily
classy get him two bottles of that a
month sitting take three of those twice
a day and what would you do for the
reflux obviously he needs some ultimate
enzymes he needs to take those a little
you know right as you start a meal and
again watch his diet very carefully yeah
and then you know two of the ultimate
enzymes would be two bottles of months
he ultimate enzyme so you can take two
of those just a couple of minutes for
each meal a couple ounces of water what
would you do to really quickly stop the
bloating he could take some get some
peppermint oil from that our ancient
legacy oils thing and take that yeah
take take five drops of the peppermint
oil and eight ounces of warm water hot
water like- peppermint tea and sip on
that it's just dramatic very dramatic
that bloating it just goes away in
seconds it's amazing and do give us a
call every couple of weeks for a similar
because your son is going to see huge
benefits from this and we're dealing
with the circulation we're going to try
to save his toes here in the seat we've
seen people who are scheduled for
amputation just like your son
and just in ninety days of course they
didn't have to have the surgery because
we're able to improve the circulation
support blood flow into the feet and
everything resolved itself died because
went away it's just amazing we do this
all the time you give the body the raw
materials the genes are built to take
these raw materials and help the body
repair it so that's the stem cells doing
genes do they call us every couple of
weeks we'll walk you through this okay
let's go to colors all right let's head
to Tula Vista California and Gary you're
on with dr. Wallach area on the air
thanks dr. Wallach my question is I've
got a big big guy was going in for a
tummy tie and they discover he's got a
non-cancerous officer and they
prescribed for all a second wait three
months that doesn't sound too complete
okay well alter their cause if he has
truly got a stomach ulcer
they're caused by an infection with a
bug called Helicobacter pylori and
giving them pellet SEC is should be
criminal instead of giving them the
antibiotics
to kill that bugs of the older reveal
and he needs to get another opinion from
another gastroenterologist somewhere
else but certainly he's gotta be careful
with taking stomach acids and things
like that because he has an active ulcer
I would go ahead and get him on
something like we have all kinds of
enzymes don't have stomach acid night
nightly essence he could take that
nightly essence ahead and take to those
before each meal it's just an enzyme but
no stomach acids in it and but also
let's see here char would you do to
support his immune system well ok Gary
how much does this guy weigh is a big
guy or small guy big guy 390 pounds Oh
400 pounds okay so what would you give
him Charmaine just to support his immune
system just sort of a basic program well
obviously he needs like four healthy
really he should be taken for healthy
reason hurt digest
well yeah our digestive packs you know
digest attacks until they kill that bug
yeah okay and so ideal would be for
picking only afford three that's good
too he's not gonna make much of a dent
in it was to because he waited almost
400 pounds and so what would you do to
help him begin to lose weight quickly
well I would get him on a gluten-free
diet obviously because remember there's
a pasture we you know have you having
your presentation and she has probably
lost my god over 300 what over 300
pounds you yeah I mean and she's just
getting out of going free diet in 90
days she lost 50 pounds without even
taking any products and then she started
taking our products to retain away and
in two weeks so getting on a gluten free
diet immediately is going to help him
lose weight but then to addition to
additionally lose weight he needs to get
on the road rev or Evie but 'el I go
ahead and get two bottles of that for
him Gary I swear this guy can take a
dropper full one not a drop but a
dropper full under his tongue thirty
minutes for each meal a second dropper
full under his tongue 15 is for each
meal and leave it absorbs her old
tissues if he swallows it it won't her
but he won't get maximum benefit he's
got to leave it at issues within a
couple of days the Shar said he'll start
losing a half a pound of 2 pounds a day
and the miracle is he will not gain the
weight back as long as he takes his 90
essential nutrients and stays away from
the bad foods fried foods processed
meats oils and gluten no olive oil
coconut oil no margins managed shelters
and cooking oils and wouldn't hurt for
him just so he understands what's going
on here to get a hold of that book
Hell's Kitchen the subtitle being oh and
if he wants to he can also get the Quito
caramel shakes and Aikido camo bars he
can have two meals a day of one of those
okay and that will help him lose the
weight control the calories we'll be
back with dead doctors don't lie after
these meals
oh you're listening to dead doctors
don't lie are the CBS Radio Network with
your host dr. Joel Wallach
[Music]
imagine a rich decadent chocolate that's
actually good for you
young gemenese triple treat chocolate is
just that an antioxidant rich dark
chocolate complete with probiotics to
aid in proper digestion this all-natural
product contains no preservatives and
for those with dietary restrictions its
gluten-free dairy-free glycemic friendly
and kosher certified not only does
triple treat dark chocolate tastes
fantastic
it contains super antioxidant
blueberries to absorb free radicals with
an ORAC value of sixteen thousand nine
hundred and thirty six per piece triple
treat chocolate also contains a
proprietary blend of probiotics with
over 500 million live healthy bacteria
per eight grams at the time of
manufacture with 80 percent reaching the
intestines which is much more than most
live culture yogurts if you'd like to
learn more about nutritional
supplementation call your local
youngevity associate and don't forget to
ask about home-based business
opportunities hello Judy Deville vez
here if I could only afford to get one
product out of everything that product
would be the ultimate classic it has the
vitamins the minerals the bio flavonoids
it even has grapeseed extract the one
product that would give you just about
everything under the Sun you would need
for a perfect nutritional program would
be the ultimate classic by the way
people that are on the go it's very very
hard to take the liquids with them when
they go on their trip to get their
supplements in everyday well you know
something you can use the ultimate daily
tablets and the mineral capsules when
I'm going on a trip if I have enough
room I just take the two bottles with me
if not just use a little baggie and take
a couple of daily doses with you it's
very simple it's very easy there's no
mess no fuss no refrigeration just take
your capsules take your tablets and your
finish for the day to order these
products call your local youngevity
distributor today you've listed a
physician and veterinarian dr. Joel
Wallach helped many people on the dead
doctors don't lie talk radio program
you've also heard hundreds of people
tell how dr. Wallach and youngevity
products have
change their lives if you're now
convinced that dr. Wallach is on to
something and you want to try your
Japanese premium quality products for
yourself we could connect you with a
distributor that serves your local area
simply call our special helpline
voicemail at three one three four four
four 3463
that's three one three four four four
three four six three call right now and
leave your name telephone number or
email address and we'll see to it that
the right person contacts you shortly
remember the phone number three one
three four four four 3463 that's three
one three four four four three four six
three call down to change your life
that's three one three four four four
[Music]
we're back with dead doctors don't lie
on the CBS radio network dr. Joel while
I care for you and giving ninth lecture
Satan Doug let's go to colors let's head
to San Rafael California and Susy Arad
with dr. Wallach hello Suzie you're on
the air thank you nice to speak with you
today
thank you how do we help you I'm five
one and a half I weigh a hundred and
eight pounds I've been on your healthy
years start pack and some other
supplements they added in for three
years and I'm doing fabulous I wanted to
know if there's anything else I should
be doing for the things that I have
going on but they're they're getting
better and those things are what's going
on osteoporosis I was diagnosed with
Hashimoto's which I have reduced my
medication because of your subway and I
had some varicose veins and spider being
we're starting ok very good
all right did you have any history of
things like eczema dermatitis or asthma
when you're a kid not as a child no
later on as an arrow
yes rosacea okay I had my gallbladder
out well they always do that when you
have pain in your belly okay wrong but
that's what they do
they got to do something right okay sure
what would you do for this kind lady
Susie well she needs to get on a
gluten-free diet absolutely no fried
food no processed meats no oils and
glutens and what you do she got on she
approaches you had thyroid problems she
got varicose veins well I would get her
on one healthy brain and heart PEC for
these issues and I would also get around
some oceans gold for the thyroid ish
yeah get her two bottles of gold st.
Kate's here those talents twice a day
what would you do for the osteoporosis
um well she gets she gets the calcium in
her and her pack so take some extra I
like the liquid I like sto Cal okay take
another you know take a half ounce of Oz
you
breakfast and dinner that's the court
what you do either she's got to go
outside for six hours a day in her
bikini bottoms and sitting or what yeah
that she can take some vitamin d3
yeah vitamin d3 you three capsules twice
a day or three spritzes from our liquid
citrus vitamin d3 I get that bottom in
d3 up and take the extra calcium mm-hmm
is who we already talked about the
thyroid and we talked about the ferric
Otis vein so would you give her extra
for the varicose veins Oh rigorous vain
she could take some extra selenium there
you go it's not the selenium but it's
the selenium product was the cofactors
in the selenium actually support healthy
elastic fibers in veins and so deals
with spider veins varicose veins
hemorrhoids with your varicose veins in
a funny place even more dangerous a
ruptured aneurysms and atriums tend not
to give you any symptoms you just drop
dead if they blow in your brain or or
they blow in your chest and you have a a
artic aneurysm or something there's tend
to be asymptomatic until you die and so
when you get the red warning lights of
spider veins varicose veins hemorrhoids
if you have white and greater silver
hair that one nutrient deficiency also
causes loss of hair color so I'd kind of
go that direction and then call us every
couple of week we'd love to hear from
you see we like to hear from people
who've been using the products for a
couple years and they see improvement
they want to know what they can throw in
and add to the program to make it even
better
we call it tweaking it you want to add
something and when things get better and
what and one little piece doesn't get
better with us apiece it gives you the
clue what you're really missing we need
to add too and so I think we've done
that so it was calling two weeks in four
weeks in six weeks a nice thing about
being in California you call your heart
are in today you get it like ship
tomorrow and you'll get it the next day
it's like two days from the day harder
it because you live in California it's
very very good you learn where the or
the company warehouse as you can go
there and pick up your art or weren't
even at space shipping or you can get on
auto-ship and not pay shipping we'll pay
the shipping if you get on auto-ship and
these things just come earlier basis as
taking off your debit cards your credit
cards with everyone and it's just one of
those things just it's magic okay and
save on the shipping there's another 8%
okay how much time we have here Doug
we're just about there we're just about
there okay well I want to invite
everybody to contact a young giving you
so you say hey you guys haven't the
meeting I want to come there and find
out more about youngevity don't forget
we are publicly traded on the stock
market Nasdaq our stock symbol is ygy I
think about buying some stock well thank
you everybody great to testimonies and
questions a thank you sh are super job
thank you Doug and fans do protic dubs
usual god bless each and every one of
you god bless her god bless our Navy
SEALs and god bless america
[Music]
you